as i was watching it again last night uh
i kept wondering could they because you
go for such a realistic and grounded
experience with this film
are there other dc superheroes in this
world is this something where it's like
do you know what i mean like could could
a superman exist in this batman world or
is it sort of these are separate things
i mean the thing that was important to
me was i felt that to
it's a high wire act to do a batman
movie right you're cause because the
character's been around for 80 years
everyone has their own version in their
head and there have been great movies so
the last thing i wanted to do was come
in there and feel like i had to do the
something with the highest degree of
difficulty and then also find the ways
that it connects to everything else so
my thing was from the beginning i said
look i think it's enough to try and just
do
a bat verse to do a batman movie and
that that's where this begins
it's you know i suppose it's not
impossible to believe that some where
somewhere down the line they could
connect to something else but that was
not my interest in this and it's not my
interest in what we would do in
follow-ups at the moment either i really
want i feel like the whole point in us
working with this incredible cast and
this incredible crew to realize this
movie that sort of i really believe is a
fresh and different version of these
characters is to pursue there are a lot
of great characters in the gotham world
and so the idea of leaning into that
that's really my interest right now
totally and i in in no way shape or form
do i want to see superman show up in in
a sequel i'm just curious if it exists
is that what you're saying i mean if it
if something like that did happen
because i was very careful about to me
what i try to do is take you know i did
this in the apes films too and even
cloverfield this idea of taking the one
fantastical element and then have it
everything around it should be as
grounded as possible so that it could
feel i want it to feel emotionally real
and to make everything feel very
believable and so in this movie even
further i think than what i did in those
films there's i tried to find the
practical believable version so if
suddenly batman i mean if suddenly in
the batman world you f you discovered
that there was an alien that was
superman there'd be a lot of shock i
mean people would have to say oh my god
and maybe that would be the one
fantastical element but to be honest
with you that is not the intention at
this point to figure out how to make
that come
if you know look we should be so lucky
that this is a world that people embrace
and that they say like oh my god we want
to see what would happen when those
things collide i think if that challenge
ever presents itself it would be an
exciting one to explore but i'd have to
try and do it through this lens you know
what i mean and that is absolutely right
that at the moment to me
this world is the place that i want to
focus